black against such an aggressive player
like report uh comes with some risk
entails so okay meanwhile a close
sicilian we're used to seeing open
sicilians at this top level
the close sicilian may be dropping out
of fashion ever since the days of
spassky the former world champion and uh
okay magnus using a very provocative
style in the opening look at black's
rook on this left side of the board it's
already moved and it's only moved four
or five that is rare at this early stage
embracing this tournament and he wants
to make his mark yeah and uh getting
into the spirit of things i feel and uh
i'm kind of curious because i must admit
this was one of my favorite openings
when i was younger and okay here comes
the quirkiness here comes the madness
because now we have a move that's never
been seen before surprise surprise and
it's initiating chaos um they always
teach players the basics they look at
the world champions they look at all the
classic games but he used that classical
training
to kind of inspire his creative juices
his creative style and that's why
pushing pawns on both on this left side
both of them now have created maximum
tension and finally white's knight comes
in yeah and i think we'll see white
castle over the next move or two okay he
does that now so white is the first to
get ready and uh we call this the closer
cillian but it might well open up later
at the moment no pawn trades no peace
trades that's why it's a close sicilian
but
not
of this one available using your
experience now
yeah this this one is uh quite flexible
i'm not quite sure why i like it and uh
yeah you know they often grimaced when
they looked at my positions but didn't
matter because
you when you play these positions out
you get a feel for them and here richard
is actually doing
all the things that you should be doing
you know he's uh taking the
he's bringing the knight into the center
this is also another kind of standard
idea that you get and it's also a
consequence of magnus actually
retreating his knight
yeah and uh finally the later lead
magnus does castle and i'm expecting
richard here to try and trade off these
dark squared bishops there we go
but via an unusual way richard to aim at
later so really interest uh interesting
strategy
there was actually a big threat in the
position earlier as well with these pawn
pushes to push everything forward in the
center with white but uh richard he's
taken a slower approach now and uh he'll
wait before pushing more pawns forward
okay there magnus goes those dots go
fishing
52 minutes left in the auction to bid
for uh our charity chess cup yes oh and
i have to say one thing about this uh
it's a really good cupcake it definitely
is it's there we go yes and uh meanwhile
as well uh kai you mentioned the
fianchetto
two bishops that were being cathode have
been traded off but look at the
remaining bishops they're both
fianchettoed as well both from the
longest diagonal uh those light-squared
bishops now there's a few pieces in the
way but they're kind of staring off
against each other and
i must admit this mysterious move there
by richard rapport tucking his king in
the corner
usually that's a safe-ish idea but here
it stands on the same diagonal as the
black bishop so slightly surprising also
there was no real danger against the
white king the white knights were really
close they're great defenders um so it
feels as if richard he's just kind of
waiting and seeing what magnus what plan
magnus goes for the f7 pawn and move it
two squares forward just to potentially
block up any king side expansion
and uh well magnus has decided just to
maneuver and improve his knight gives
black maybe some control of dark squares
in the center and talking of dark
squares richard decides okay it's not
yet time to throw the spawn forward
all this pawn forward instead he just
covers those dark squares this is very
logical as well once you've traded off
dark squared bishops you might as well
put your pawns on dark squares you need
some influence on that color complex and
he is not ready to sit passively and
wait for the white pawns to advance he's
doing the same himself and he's trying
to create his own version there's only
three of them but he's only he's trying
to create his own version of uh of the
pawn storm he hasn't played that many
elite events compared to some of the
others uh for example there will be
players in the uh candidates who have
played world championship matches before
and he hasn't quite been there meanwhile
he does block it up look at all those
white pawns on dance squares now um
that's
aesthetically at least pleasing but uh
yeah richard he's also the kind of guy
who can beat anyone on his day unlike
the other top players he doesn't have a
team behind him he's just uh he has his
great support from his wife johanna
definitely but uh really
there's uh no other teams to help him he
doesn't have any seconds he does a lot
of his work by himself preferences a lot
of top players as we saw in the world
championship match in the publishing
there he ended up playing openings that
his seconds recommended but it didn't
really suit his style so yeah richard
very much uh individual player and uh he
embraces that and yeah i'm struggling to
find a move here for magnus maybe he has
to open things up maybe he has to trade
off some pawns because i'm getting
scared after you mentioned the word
checkmate ivanka i'm kind of scared the
black king has just been abandoned to
its fate and white tonight as we
mentioned is about to jump in with some
nasty checks
and okay he doesn't go for this as you
mentioned ivanka now this rook is
eternally locked out of the game this is
a real thorn in white side really far
advanced down the board but then again
white would have ideas of just jumping
in and checking this black king very
much black controlling the left side
white controlling the right side instead
magnus deciding okay this one is too
blocked too locked up and actually
blocked positions rapport does tend to
thrive
just because he's able to
use his creativity with maneuvers so
magnus instead opens things up so he's
trying to angle for a potential queen
trade these pawns because black's knight
is defending it he's going for it he's
going through the attack um now i was
going to say white tonight can jump in
and look at these two white knights
together they are aiming towards this
black king richard who looks more
confident with the two and okay magnus
does indeed grab a pawn yeah
okay he's going for it okay oh my god
this is like a typical kind of bobby
fischer type of attack you know bobby
doesn't care about the left side of the
board he's going all in for the
checkmate magnus the computer thinks
he's doing well uh but
wow such a calm move just pushing a pawn
forward one square he wants to use this
rook on the second rank maybe ivanka as
you mentioned that white rook on the a2
square maybe wants to swing across and
help the attack
and i was going to use a word that i
know simon our good friend
ginger gm uses all the time he says uh
it's a discombobulating move
confusing
and talking of discombobulation uh these
black knights are really confusing me
and i'm pretty sure they're confusing
rapport because magnus one of his
knights was attacked he just left it on
pres as we say he left it attacked the
other black knight has joined the action
and look at that white rook on the a2
square shouldn't uh
shouldn't really
scare you nope it uh it isn't one night
it's two nights at least temporarily for
a report and he's jumped in with a check
i'm expecting to see the king step
forward if you step into the corner then
it's more likely you'll actually get
checkmated on the side of the board for
example as we mentioned if the queen
comes in
and tries to go for your king at least
as magnus is done at least with the king
here and meanwhile maybe you don't have
that luxury of four or five moves your
rook is attacked wow rapport just
gambling giving away everything he's
decided
it's not worth saving this rook it's not
worth saving this pawn he's just brought
his queen in and uh okay it's the last
chance for him the computer shows this
doesn't work but is magnus gonna call
his bluff if magnus takes this rook
what is his idea if he calculates
correctly he'll see that he is winning
but you never know okay he does find
this move multi-purpose move and uh it
looks like the world champion is going
to take this one the attack just too
slow for report yeah it's uh it's
looking difficult rapport lifting his
queen up one square oh maybe a bit
tricky there may be some ideas in mind
as you've mentioned of the white knight
dropping back with a check but the other
move you mentioned the defensive
resource will end this game because one
of white's
pride enjoys those nights it has been
removed now white only has two potential
attackers the queen and knight and faced
with several defenders it's not going to
be enough trade off your opponent's
attackers and you have to remember three
is the magic number and there were three
potential attackers brewing and richard
unfortunately had to take a time out to
capture the the bishop
and uh
queen and knight's not going to be
sufficient
okay threatening checkmates let's try
and show this just while magnus tries to
figure out the final touches maybe we
can keep an eye on the players
because we might see a reaction any
moment now white white's rook has indeed
dropped and this rook is attacked as
well ivanka mentioned a check but the
problem is the king hides in the corner
and okay this is going to happen no more
checks and also there's tension between
the queens so white's knight i think is
going to jump back to where it came from
threatening to deliver a checkmate but
maybe black can deal with this in a few
ways and one of them i see is just to
bring the rook across and act as a
defender now white's queen and knight
actually teaming up threatening
checkmate on this square but black can
just defend with his rook and uh i think
we're going to see this this rook acting
as a defender might just end the game
richard might well resign here because
he's simply a rook down and another rook
attacked and let's go back to the
players will we see a result after this
last move this rook move using the rook
as a defender will end the game just not
enough attacking pieces left richard now
he's down a rook and he's down two pawns
and there we go he does resign wow he
resigns after 29 moves against magnus
cross